so go ahead and update the query
conferences function to use filters this
time make sure you're editing the query
conferences method not the playground
method that you were using before so
things you're going to need to do going
to need to get the conference query
formats the lesson 4 folder and put it
in the form package of your project
you're going to need to update the
signature of query conferences in
conference API to take an input
parameter of conference query form and
then just call conference query form get
query to actually run the query and then
optionally if you want the optimization
to preload the organizers profile
entities so what are some of the things
that you need to be aware of including a
UI like the show conferences page that
lets users add multiple filters in any
order do you have to consider whether
the deployed app has to have composite
indexes for every filter combination do
you have to think about the fact that
multiple filters per query increase the
data store rights and you need to think
about whether multiple index entries
take up more space in the data store